is in Missouri she says is it necessary
to hire a financial adviser when
investing I can open a Roth IRA and
college fund at my local credit union
what does a financial adviser do that
makes using one worthwhile I would never
buy investments at a credit union or a
bank ever their bankers it's a whole
different skill set no chance I'm buying
I don't buy mufflers at the transmission
store either and I don't buy shoes at
the hair salon I mean think about it no
no no no no no you're going to get a
simple savings account if you go into
the financial institution or you're
gonna get bad investment advice from
somebody don't know what the flip
they're doing never do that what does a
financial adviser do a good mutual fund
financial adviser like our smart Wester
pros that we recommend it on the smart
Wester program as an example what do
they do well a good one the only ones we
recommend has the heart of a teacher now
about 85% of people in the investment
sales world are salesmen about 15% of
teachers you're looking for the teacher
if you feel like you got slimed and you
need to take a shower after meeting with
somebody then you did not find a teacher
you found the slime ball that's pushy
salesmen and that they're everywhere but
that is not who you want what you want
is a teacher the reason is is that you
are gonna make your own financial
decisions after being taught but you can
learn a lot about any given subject from
a subject matter expert I don't do my
own taxes I have a tax professional I
know a lot about taxes I'm really good
with math I could probably figure it out
but a tax professional can
help me through the complications of it
and make me more money keep me from
sending government money that I need to
send them I don't do my own estate
planning I know a lot about estate
planning but I'll do my own I have a
lawyer that is a professional estate
planner he spends all day every day at
work studying estates and estate
planning he knows more than I do
he's a subject matter expert that makes
him worth his money I don't even work on
my own cars anymore I used to could work
on a car back when the cars were actual
engines but I can't work on them anymore
you have to you have to reboot a car now
you can't it's like a computer or
something so I can't work on them
anymore
so what do I do I don't go I can lift
the I've got a whole bunch of tools in
my garage I could lift the hood and
probably wander around in there and
after a few days I could figure it out
but it's a lot more efficient for me
time wise and knowledge wise to have
somebody that actually knows what the
flip they're doing work on my car
instead of doing it myself it's an
interesting thing we hire professionals
all through our lives why is it when it
comes to investing we think we don't
need a professional I don't understand
because there's all kinds of studies
that show when you have a financial
advisor that teaches you and is there to
talk you off the ledge when the Dow
Jones Industrial Average drops and it's
in the evening news they talk you off
the ledge and keep you from selling
buying high and selling low I supposed
to do it the other way around if you
didn't know supposed to buy low and sell
high but that's what a financial adviser
does they actually are subject matter
expert I know Oh about investing Oh II's
aliy could do my own investing and I
don't I used one of our smart mister
pros why why would I do that because the
guy I work with has been in the business
for 30 years 20 years ain't he he
studies mutual funds all day long every
day I don't
he can sit down and go this meet your
fun is this this mutual fund says and he
can pull up the software that he owns
and run the run the hypotheticals and
there's what we've got and here's what
the history isn't is that tape so huge
time savings for me I don't spend my
whole life studying mutual funds I
really don't want to I don't like mutual
funds very much I don't have to study
them all day every day
I don't either do something fun that
sounds painful to me that's why you use
a financial advisor they know more than
you and they can coach you and teach you
they are subject matter experts and we
use subject matter experts in every area
of our lives so just go to Dave Ramsey
com click smart Buster put in your info
drops down a list of smart mister pros
in your area that we are recommending